Hello, and welcome to
GDL-IL, GDL Israel.
Today we're going to speak
about Compute Engine.
And I'll try to show you how
easy it is to start a new
instance of your own virtual
machine on Google
infrastructure.
And since in most of the cases,
we're talking here in
Google Developer Live Israel
about entrepreneurship,
start-ups, and front
end development.
I'll try to show you how you
could quickly create a micro
instance, install Apache on it
and from there you could take
it and do some clever,
amazing things.
Of course, you could take these
same exact steps and
install any other piece of
software that you would like
to install on a new
virtual Linux box.
It could be node.js.
It could be [? nyc.js. ?]
It could be lots of
other things.
So let's jump and see.
I'll show my screen.
And as you can see here, if you
go to cloud.google.com,
you'll have quite a lot of
different products that today
we are supporting.
Right now, in this episode,
so we're going to focus on
Compute Engine.
However, if you want platform
as a service, and you are
developing your service site in
Java, iPhone, [? GO, ?] or
PHP, App Engine might be an even
more suitable solution.
Definitely if you're doing
something nice in terms of
your ATI, so Cloud Endpoint
could be a
great product for that.
Or you just want to build some
web service and support it
from App Engine.
With App Engine, you're
basically running in a certain
container that Google is
maintaining, scaling, and
taking care of all the quote,
unquote, "redundant" jobs that
you don't want to do as your
own system administrator.
You want to focus on what you're
good at, and write your
amazing software.
Other things that we have--
we'll try to touch them in the
next few weeks-- will be cloud
storage and Cloud SQL.
And, of course, BigQuery, the
ability to run clever queries
on billions of rows and
get the results in
less than a few seconds.
So as we said, Compute Engine
basically lets you run Linux
virtual machines, and talking
to them, and do whatever you
want with those machines.
Let's see how I could do it.
If you'll go to Google Cloud
Console like I have here,
probably you won't have
too many projects
like I do here but.
But in this case, you're
just clicking
on Create New Project.
And I did it already just to
save time, and you'll get all
the different options of what
you want to do in this
specific project.
Now in our case, we choose
the Compute Engine.
And, of course, we need
to enable billing.
In App Engine, you have the
ability to run up to 12
projects without any billing.
So if you want just to test
things inside App Engine, just
choose this far now.
If you want to try Compute
Engine, you will need to
enable billing.
Lucky for us and to save time,
I already prepared a project
with billing enabled.
And if we'll go into it, you
could see here that you have
several things that
you could do with.
One, I already created a box.
And I created a micro version
of it because we don't need
too much if you want just
to run one, let's say,
development server, and testings
up in the cloud.
If you click on this line,
you'll get quite a lot of
different things that
are attaching to
this specific box.
And, for us, maybe what's
important here is the zone.
So it could be in the United
States or in Europe and, in
our case, in Israel,
I choose Europe.
The external IP so we could
reach this machine, and of
course, some other parameters,
like the disk and the network.
Down here at the bottom, you
have the ability to see how
you want to communicate
with the specific box.
In our case, we choose SSH, and
to work with SSH, we have
this nice GC SQL tool, that
after you install it--
and it's quite easy.
Four steps, four clicks and
you're installing it--
you run this specific
command in order to
connect to your box.
Now as I said, I already
attached to this box.
Now let's see just
that I share the
right screen with you.
Let's cancel this screen share,
and I'll try to share
my desktop so you'll be able to
see everything that I do.
Let's close this one, and here
we already connected basically
to our box.
And as you can see here, I first
just want to show all
the different packages
that I have.
I have 230, so it's
not too much.
All the essential packages that
you will want to see when
you start to do things.
And here you could get, of
course, a more thorough look
of all the different packages
that you have.
And as you can see up here, what
I previously did already
is, I just run this one command
of Sudo, App Get,
Install Apache 2.
And now in our case, of course,
it's already there so
it's letting me know
that it's there.
But if it wasn't, was just
downloading and installing it
for me, now that I have it, I
could go, of course, to this
location of var.dub.dub.dub.
And here I just want to
see what files I have.
I have, of course, a different
index HTML file that Apache is
bringing to me.
And to make things a bit
nicer, I also put
that To Do List app.
Of course, they have all of
the MV-Star frameworks.
And with a little twist of using
a leverage IndexDB so
everything will be the same
for us locally as well.
And if I'm going to now to,
let's take here, my instance.
And in the instance I could
see the external IP.
Right now I don't have any
DNS settings for it.
I'll just go here, put it.
And, of course, we're getting
the first Hello World of
Apache, but if I'll just go
here and try to go to the
special demo that I prepared.
So you can see here that
we have all the nice
capabilities here.
And, of course, if I'm
refreshing everything, it's
still working and I could delete
stuff, and it's a quite
nice application.
If I want to change it or to
change anything, let's see how
this works.
Of course, I'm just coming here,
and entering the file.
Hello all.
Should be L, I, L. Yours.
Thank you for watching.
After I saved it, and
I'm refreshing--
you could see here that I'm
having a full control.
One thing that you want to
remember is that when you go
in here, you have the ability
and you should go to network
and basically make sure, if
you want to have certain
settings to your own network,
you have full control of it,
if you want to take a snapshot
and save the data and the
state this specific instance,
you could create a new
snapshot, and it would basically
allow you to save
all the data that you
right now have in
this specific machine.
And then replicate it and create
new machines out of
this instance.
Another nice thing to note is,
when you're coming to this
console and on network, you
could go to the default.
And here you have fewer
firewalls that you
might want to set.
Of course, internal IPs
we are allowing.
And then if you need the SSH
like we did here, of course,
it's open by default.
And then what you want to do in
this case is just to enable
the web server firewall.
Because if you want to allow it
to access on TCP and heed
the server, you won't be able
to reach these pages.
Let's just for fun try to
delete this firewall.
And as you can see here,
it's now deleting it.
And if I'm refreshing and I want
to check it again, I see
now that I don't have it here.
And now if I try to reach our
Hello World page, you could
see that I can't do that.
So very important to remember
to basically create a new
instance and to give it-- if
you'll try to put [INAUDIBLE],
it will let you know
that we're only
getting things like this.
So in our case, I'll do TCP.
And, of course, the name
will be Web Server.
And I'll create it.
You could see how quickly,
basically, it's creating
everything for you.
And once this is done, I'm
coming again here and hitting
it, and everything is
back to normal.
So I think we pretty much
covered the main things.
As you saw, it's quite easy to
establish a new instance, run
with it, have new packages
and models that will
make you more efficient.
And from that on, you have all
the nice abilities of taking
snapshots, controlling images,
and having all the metadata
and operations of what you do.
You could choose quite a lot
of different images.
I chose Debian but there's lots
of [INAUDIBLE] as well.
And two other things that you
might want to check are, as I
mentioned, you're hitting
cloud.google.com, but you have
two other locations if you
could work and check what
you're doing.
One will be called [INAUDIBLE]
google.com APIs.
And here you could basically see
what you're doing on each
and every project and what
APIs you're using or
allowing for it.
The other location is the App
Engine dashboard, so it would
be on AppEngine.google.com.
And here you could see all your
projects and, of course,
in our case, see exactly
what's going on
on the server itself.
So I think we covered most of
the things that we wanted, and
I think next time.
Thank you very much.